foreign
how I could prepare emotionally for
having more kids when the labor and
postpartum experience was my first kid
was really bad in a word anytime
somebody says it was really bad and they
start laughing it was super bad
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
delone show
welcome to the greatest mental health
marriage and parenting podcast that has
ever existed we talk about everything
whatever's going on in your life
do my best at medical stuff you although
I usually tell you to go see your doctor
we talk about education we talk about
your mental health we talk about what's
going on your marriage and your life and
your kids heart and mind whatever is
going on your life I'll sit with you and
we will
come up with the next right step for you
to take and I'm honored by your time and
I'm honored by your trust and so thank
you for joining us
um don't forget you can really help out
your neighbor if you will just do
something as simple as leave a five star
review or hit the Subscribe button it's
a gift because it throws it up in the
algorithms and I don't know how the
machine Learners are doing whatever
they're doing but it puts it in front of
more people and it gives people more
access to something that is we are all
in desperate need of and that is hope
that is light in a messy messy
I see World
um and don't and also I'm a part of a
network the Ramsay Network and if you
want to get the Ramsay Network app
um the the Ramsay show about money uh my
friend Rachel Cruz and and George
Campbell have a show Rachel's got a show
Ken's got a show
um on Career if you're wondering where
to transition your job so download the
Ramsay Network app and there's a bunch
of shows with my friends and colleagues
and partners and uh check it out all
right let's go to Maria in Richmond
Virginia what's up Maria
hello thank you for having me on the
show and thank you for calling what's up
um I was wondering how I could prepare
emotionally for having more kids when
the labor and postpartum experience was
my first kid was really bad in a word
tell me tell me what
anytime somebody says it was really bad
and they start laughing it was super bad
um tell me how tell me what really bad
means
um so I was in labor for over two full
days
um I had to transfer to a hospital when
I was planning on having a home birth
and I pushed for six hours
and
um
after he was born there was some like
when I was getting stitched up I could
feel it and I told the nurse to stop and
she didn't
um so like that was also not great and
then when we got home my son didn't
sleep for the first year of his life
um
yeah so like he's just over a year now
and he's just starting to sleep and I'm
just starting to feel
sort of like a normal person again human
again yeah so this was more
did you did you experience any
postpartum symptoms or was this just
like a
uh I I mean it was a traumatic birth
experience
yeah okay
um yeah I mean I do think there was some
postpartum and depression postpartum
depression and anxiety happening sure um
I'm that's just a guess I should have
gotten help and I didn't but um yeah
so
man I I think your fear of what comes
next is legitimate and real
I mean it it was it it was a scary thing
and it was a painful painful thing and
it was a loss of control and it was
probably made worse by every one of your
girlfriends telling you it's so
beautiful and lovely and great and
you're on Pinterest the week before and
all these birth are holding their babies
and smiling like it's all shiny and you
know you know what I mean it's like you
had this picture of what this was gonna
be and they're gonna lay your baby down
on your chest and it's gonna be skin to
skin contact and you're gonna feel this
moment and instead you're screaming and
your legs are so cramped up you can't
move and you'll go to the bathroom and
in six to seven weeks because whatever
and then yeah this kid won't sleep I
don't even like him even though he's my
baby and then I feel guilty and shameful
because I don't like my kid right it
just it's not how we drew it up right
yeah so that's an accurate picture do
you want to have more kids
yes why what do you want to do why do
you want to go down this road again
because I know when I'm like 70 I'll be
really mad if the thing that's talk to
me was being scared of one year being
difficult
[Laughter]
that's one way to look at it and I'm not
even gonna take that from you you are
allowed to have that as your as your
your picture
um
so a friend of mine
um she had a pretty remarkable
experience with postpartum and then she
ended up
um like you know making sense of that
making meaning of that by sitting with a
number of women who have different birth
experiences she's a professor at a med
school I'm really remarkable woman
um and she had a very similar
much more graceful approach than you but
she said like her approach was
um
picture your Thanksgiving table in 20
years
and then back it up to
today
and when we were discussing it back and
forth I asked her is is this a tell me
if this is a good analogy I want to have
X dollars in my retirement account in 25
years so what decisions do I need to
make right now knowing that
um it's going to take this long for this
to happen and she said absolutely so
here's what I would suggest one is I
would be really clear with my OB GYN
coming into this new season and if it's
time to get a new OB GYN get a new get a
new doctor okay okay I wouldn't I
wouldn't think twice about that you had
a terrible experience they didn't listen
to you or go back to the if you trust
this person and it was just a weird
experience or it's rushed or too slow
whatever
say I don't want to do this again
the second is somebody who has had
I mean you had a home birth in mind that
tells me you really researched this
thing right I want it to look like this
I want to experience it like this a lot
of your
I don't want to be dismissive of the
pain and all that because that stuff is
super real and Wild
but a lot of your angst can come from
the gap between what you wanted to
happen and what actually happened
and often the the that Gap I call it
grief and grieving like I wanted to be
like this and it wasn't there's
something about owning reality okay this
is reality and so this time I'm not
gonna plan a home birth or this time I
am going to plan a home birth and I'm
gonna be a little more strategic about
it whatever
it's owning what could actually happen
and here's the third part and this is
the not popular part
um and this is my friend told me this
and this is what the the clinical
literature says
if you've had a hard like a long
um labor
prep for it next time
before you get pregnant start an
exercise routine start a meditation
practice start eating right yeah get as
much sleep as you can with a with a
one-year-old and I'm saying that knowing
that's obnoxious but
um
put yourself in as good a physical
position as a physical shape as you can
knowing that you're gonna have to do 48
Hours of absolute physical health
you see what I'm saying okay and it will
give you some control it may not make
labor any nicer or not nicer or whatever
maybe just
world-class crap show but let's give
ourselves the best chance on the front
end let's control what we can control
right yeah and let's do the let's let's
put the money in the account While We're
Young while we can so that when things
happen down the road we're ready for it
and really I don't know another I don't
know a lot of other options what do you
think
no I think that's
I've already started to I've tried to
start doing that but again with a
one-year-old it can be kind of a joke it
can be but also
um don't let it be a joke I want you to
go to my friends
um the Mind pump guys and they have a
new Pro they have a whole list of
workout programs called maps maps and
they just released one called Maps 15.
it's a 15 minute workout that they use
and these dudes are Beefcake McGee's
they're all smoke shows like Kelly and I
went to visit the studio and Kelly had
to catch her breath right they're like
but but this workout program is 15
minutes a day you can do that for the
one-year-old you can't do that okay I
can do that you get a couple of
dumbbells and a couple and you can do 15
minutes and my guess is my wife made a
really took the why to the cleaners on
the the child care
and she went to the gym for an hour
sometimes maybe two hours sometimes
maybe four hours until they were like
paging Miss deloney right but
um some of these gyms have free child
care and it might be a great way for you
to get some space to read a book to
journal some to exercise right take a
class be around other people so utilize
some of that stuff
um what I would say is
foreign
we have a real it's a cultural issue and
so I don't want to project this onto you
because it may not be the case in your
home but culturally speaking we've made
our children especially young kids the
epicenter of our planet
and I would suggest you control alt
delete your calendar a year in
and say okay I'm not going to go through
a day and not exercise
how is my kid going to be a part of that
not how can I fit exercise into my kids
world
okay I'm not budging on this so kid
you're coming to the Y child care and
you know what everybody's gonna live
it's gonna be fine and I'm gonna become
a mom who sleeps at night a mom who's a
little less stressed a little less
anxious because I'm I'm taking care of
myself I've got to go be with other
people so kid you're gonna have to
figure this out because mom's gonna go
be with her friends and other people
because
my world doesn't revolve around you
because your kid can't hold your world
right they're not strong enough to hold
the epicenter of your solar system so
I'm not even let you do that you're a
moon you revolve around me right and
let's completely shift and maybe that's
something you sit down with your husband
and say hey
uh we're a year in we've survived let's
start building a life that we want not
settling for a life that we think we
have to have because we have this 14
pound screaming thing in the house that
poops and eats and never sleeps does
that make sense yeah
um as the great Rage Against the Machine
said Maria it's time for you to uh take
your power back right take ownership of
your home and take ownership of okay
I got my butt kicked last time during
um during labor it was rough
um
I lost control of the picture that I'd
planned so long for my body didn't
respond how I thought it was going to uh
I ended up in a in a physical exertion
like I physically exerting myself in a
way that I wasn't prepared for my nurse
didn't listen to me I had surgery
without anesthesia right all these
things
here's what I can control going ahead
next time and recognizing it might be
really really rough again
and that's what we're going to double
down like you said I'm not gonna when
I'm 70 I'm gonna hate myself I would
probably wouldn't go there
but what's the table I want one in 20
years and what hard things do I have to
do now
and I do think sitting down with your
doctor and saying hey this was my
experience we're about to go round two
of this and I need to have a better
experience this time I need you guys to
listen to me better I need to plan
better and uh let's be on the same page
here but congratulations I'm sorry ah
I'm sorry it was so rough this time
control we can control get people in our
lives
and let's move forward best of luck to
you hey when this new baby's born number
two send us a picture and we'll post it
for you we'll be right back
hey it's Dr John deloney here look
people are always saying the holidays
are the most wonderful time of the year
right for some of us the holidays are
great some of us the holidays are not
great but for all of us the holidays are
Mayhem you're probably traveling all
over the place talking to family members
you didn't even ask for by the way
shopping trying to deal with all the
parties and no one will turn off the
Christmas music you know who you are but
inside the chaos you still have a choice
the choice to take care of yourself and
the best way to navigate the chaos of
the holidays is to make sure you are
well and being well starts with a good
night's sleep and I found that good
sleep starts with a great mattress and
that's why my family sleeps on dream
Cloud dream Cloud mattresses combination
of gel memory foam and coil technology
keeps you comfortable all night and
right now dream cloud is running their
biggest offer ever exclusively for our
listeners 599 dollars in accessories
plus an additional 250 dollar discount
that's 849 dollars in accessories and
savings visit dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloni to get your new
mattress and start getting the rest your
body needs
all right we are back let's go to
Jackson
I think it's Chanute Kansas Jackson is
that right
yes that is correct that's Chanute
Chanute nailed it yeah it would be cool
if you called it Chanute but it's cool
Chanute it is what's up Jackson yeah hey
how you doing I'm rock onto the break of
dawn dude do you go by Jack or Jackson
Jackson listen I have a a buddy whose
kid his name Jack that's a dope name
Jackson's cool
but Jack my nephew is actually just
named Jack too so oh that's cute you
have a like a family member who likes
you
yeah I guess
my siblings don't even name their pets
after me but whatever all right so
what's up
um I'm just gonna start off by saying uh
it's kind of nerve-wracking so if you'll
just bear with me
um
so and I'm kind of going to be all over
the place but my basic question is
um I have a best friend
who's in a relationship and he's wanting
to you know in the near future whether
it's like a month or six months I don't
know the time frame he says he's saving
up a ring to buy to get engaged they
have a promise ring since like two years
ago or so so this has been going on for
a long time and they lived together and
um he's gonna ask me to be his best man
because I was his he was my best man and
it's kind of just like a you know a
known thing between us too we're going
to be each other the best man but if he
goes through with this and he you know
actually gets engaged and marries this
this woman that he's been with for like
five years
I really can't see myself
um like saying yes and and being his
best man because I can't stand by him
while he marries this this person and I
don't know if that's just like is it am
I the issue like am I you know you know
I'm not trying to control him or
anything like that I just I want to see
him Thrive and be the best himself then
this person is not helping him
um and I just I don't know what to do
and I you know some of my friends my
other like our mutual friends they uh
they agree with me and and we're gonna
hopefully talk to him sometime in the
future if that's what we should do
um I just wanted to get your thoughts on
the whole thing
um that's that's kind of where I am cool
well thanks for thanks for verbalizing
it like that and thanks for loving your
friend
um I'm gonna work
I'm gonna go to the very end of this
question and work all the way back okay
okay
um right before this show one of my best
friends in the world called and it's
going to see a counselor brilliant guy
and
uh I recommended a counselor that's like
known to be the best of the best of the
best in this particular city and state
and so my buddy went and met with the
person and they hit it off and then this
person said hey I'm not taking any new
clients but I'll take you on
um I'll we'll figure this out
I'm gonna send you all my price sheet
and you're gonna have sticker shock
and
sticker shock is the understatement very
very expensive wildly expensive and you
got to pay six months all at one like
right and but this is guys world class
and so my friend called me back and was
asking all kinds of like do you think
it's like charging like this and I I
checked up the academic credentials and
I looked at this and I was checking this
I mean back
and finally I said hey who cares
who cares if this person said I charge
five thousand dollars a session
my first thought would be dude if you
can get it get it man like high five I'm
not paying that and I'm gonna move on to
my with my day right so I told him
you're carrying a lot of existential
angst around trying to figure out why is
this person charged so much and what do
they think they're doing that justifies
this and I don't know if I can afford
this or if I can't afford I don't want
to spend that
dude like I just say like brother you're
carrying a lot of extra weight he put a
price down and I'm gonna say no thanks
have a great day and I'm gonna move on
to my next thing
so
tying that story back to you
you have a particular set of values and
you think that he should not be marrying
this person to the point that you've
chosen you've decided I'm not going to
be your best man if he asks me he's
gonna ask me I am I'm gonna say no
and so
there should be a period at the end of
that sentence
because you know what's going to come on
the back end he's been with this person
five years he's not gonna magically go
oh my gosh why you didn't you don't like
her and then he's gonna change his whole
life that's not going to be how that
that's not why you're saying no you're
saying no because I can't participate in
this not to try to get him to switch
change his mind at the last second
so whatever he does on the back end will
screw you then forget you we're done
like I'm not hanging out with you
anymore you're an idiot that's his
choice you make a grown-up decision he
gets to make a grown-up decision and you
can weep be heartbroken be sad all that
kind of stuff but you can't save your
friend like that if he hasn't invited
you in so I would make my values
decision and stand on my values
now getting a little bit closer to right
now
the part of me like I've got a couple of
close buddies like I've been in their
wedding been like all that stuff
I'm stunned that you haven't sat him
down before now and said bro I can't
stand by this or let me ask you this
question why are you waiting until he
asks you to be his best man
to let him know where you stand that
seems abjectly not cool
yeah I think I agree with that and and
me and my another friend of ours were
working to to kind of sit him down yeah
let me stop you right there what is that
this sounds like somebody I mean you
were he was the best man in your wedding
like I don't know what there is to work
up
like my best friends I call and say dude
what are you doing like that's how the
call starts or hey
I just got this text message from you
you're not all right what's what's the
deal like there's nothing to work up
like we've passed working up that's what
makes them my best man that's what makes
them like like literally my brothers
because I don't have to work up anymore
so what what is that fear that's
in a relationship that I think should be
well past all that stuff
um I think it's because I'm afraid of of
losing him after 10 years of friendship
because I don't like you know I don't
agree with you know the person he's
going to be with and uh I just am afraid
of losing him and him going well you
don't want to decide what I do you've
already left him and I'm Jackson you've
already left him
you left him
and you have every right to do that but
you're already gone
you're hanging on to a myth brother
like you already you've already decided
that when he asks me one of the most
important questions of his life I'm
going to tell him no you're already out
of this relationship
now you're hanging on to a picture of
what could be if he wasn't in this about
to get married to this person he's been
with for five years he's going to and so
reality is sailed on and you're you're
back here
this relationship has already changed
you just haven't had the courage to tell
him it's changed
is that fair
yeah that's that's fair how do I you
know how would I even another thing that
I'm kind of struggling with is how do I
even bring it up you know we never ever
talk about these things he never had a
say in my wedding why should I ever say
in his wedding is like out of the blue
I'm just like hey I don't like this
person you know like what I even where
do I even start like I don't I don't
know where to start
that's a great question so I would start
this way I would be very very clear
I've got friends who like I don't like
like I wouldn't have chosen their wives
to hang out with
but they're not bad people that might be
too loud or too quiet or too weird or
they don't think I'm funny and I'm the
best right jack like like I don't I
don't ha they wouldn't have been my
first pick but they're great people
they're good human beings and I don't
mind my kids playing with their kids and
they're great moms they're great
Partners to my friend like so
ask yourself do I just not like them or
here's two or three or five or ten ways
this person is harmful
completely dishonest cheats on you
forces you to do things that are I'm
watching my friend Wither on the fine
you used to be like this and this person
has taken this from you I've watched it
I've had a ringside seat to this so I
would be very very clear about what my
objections to this other person are
and I would so that's that's spending
time with yourself and I wouldn't even
do this with another buddy I would be
very clear about this with myself what
is it that I feel so strongly about that
I can't be involved in this relationship
at all I don't want to be in that
picture that's going to be taken at that
wedding
the second thing is I would sit down
with my friend and if you bring somebody
else to this type of conversation it's
gonna feel interventiony or gang up like
you're ganging up on him I wouldn't I
wouldn't do that
I would
um if I had this kind of relationship I
would tell him hey I failed you brother
because I haven't told you the truth for
a long long time
and I should have told you a long time
ago and I wimped out and then I just got
down the road and so here we are
um
I've watched and that's where you're
going to have that list I've watched my
friend wither away I've watched my
friend get further and further away from
the guy I've known for 10 years
and I should have called it out a long
time ago and I didn't and I I can't
sleep at night knowing how much I love
you and you're my friend of a decade
without speaking my mind and I know this
might cost our friendship and I hope it
doesn't but this I've got to be honest
and that's how I would do it I would own
the fact that you should have had this
conversation three years ago four years
ago five years ago and you didn't and so
here we are right
and just know your friend is going to
have a incredibly hard Choice Maybe
it may be a very simple choice for him
he may say oh thank God somebody finally
said something or he might say well you
just opted out of my life brother
go on about your day because I'm
marrying her and cool
you know what I mean
yeah
yeah I've ran those scenarios in my head
and I what do you what do you think is
going to happen what are you scared of
it's bigger than you think he's just
gonna walk away from a 10-year
friendship
um I mean that is basically the the
whole thing is as I come up to him and
after five years of not saying something
I'm like hey here's the facts you know
this is how I feel and he goes well then
I don't want you in my life anymore and
I lose you know we we play games
together all the time we're we're
constantly texting each other all the
time we send each other videos funny
videos and a relationship is just so
awesome
Jackson it's not because it's not a real
relationship because you're not being
honest with him
you're not telling the truth and you
haven't for years
so you all might share laughs
and I've got lots of I've got lots of
Associates people I've known for two
decades three decades that I share
laughs with then I text funny pictures
back and forth to that are on long long
text threads
but they don't know when my marriage
goes sideways
they don't know when I screw up as a dad
I got four or five men that I talk to
about that
four or five men one or two women and
those women are connected to those men
like
like there's very very few people I talk
to about that stuff
and whether you believe that or not this
guy isn't that guy because you sat
across from him for five years and kept
a huge secret from him
and so and to preserve that relationship
yeah at some point you come clean at
some point you sit down and say dude I
should have told you a long time ago and
I'm sorry I screwed up
um and I know this is going to alter
things between us and I know you're
gonna have to do what you want to do
but here's what a layout here's what it
is
here's what it is and for everybody
listening I want you to like I'm
intentionally not asking him what the
things are
because I don't want
I don't want all of us having a ringside
seat into that's not even that big a
deal or oh my gosh what
he's got to make his call outside of
like like physical
um or psychological abuse right
um outside of that he's got to make his
own call this is just against my value
against my values and I can't be a part
of this thing but I need you to get out
of the fantasy Jackson that you have
this great killer relationship because
it's not it's built on a house of
dishonesty
and so it's time to come clean
be hard if you have to write it down
write it down but it's it it's time to
come clean
and let's start
building the relationship that you
actually think you have
let's be real with it
and let the let him make a grown-up
decision that the cards fall as they
fall
we'll be right back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode's sponsor better help let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist at under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Ann and
the home of the Pirates Pittsburgh
what's up Anne
um hi Dr Delaney how are you
um good a little nervous but um I'll get
to my question that I um and left for
your show yeah I'm not very good at this
you have nothing to be nervous about
nothing
um yeah I know it's just hey I don't
like my voice on tape it sounds great I
don't know it sounds great okay all
right my my question was about
um the
gas lighting versus
um someone's story like what the
difference is because
um
I've heard that term thrown around a lot
especially in my house in the last year
or so and
um then I also heard
um between your show and your book and
you know a class I had at work recently
they talked about your people's stories
and the stories you tell yourself and I
just one of the explanation of the
differences and then how I can deal with
um you know conversations around that
let's get
instead of making this very academic and
giving definitions let's what's the
actual challenge you're facing
are people accusing you of gaslighting
them or are people gaslighting you and
store like what are you actually facing
um well
well my kids have said
um like my husband and I you know
um have Gaslight them and
um it give me an example of a a way they
say you're gaslighting them or Gaslight
them
um like saying like with their childhood
and how how they perceive it versus
um give me an example give me an example
um let me think um
yeah
here's a hard time here but here's a
couple of things because it's just it's
like an overwhelming layer of heaviness
over sure there's there's
um a few of us
um have ADHD I know I was diagnosed I
strongly believe my husband is too and
me too me too me too so yeah and the the
emotional dysregulation that had
happened in the house apparently was
causing
um
stress that you know when you walk
around like uh you're walking on
eggshells and waiting for somebody to
explode so that was I guess the
um what the kids lived with and yes
yesterday I asked my daughter about
um I had pictures of us on a bike ride
or we're talking about a bike ride that
we took that was like it ended up being
this huge long bike ride
um
on this really nice Trail and I'm like
oh do you remember that she goes well if
Dad was there I blacked it out and
I'm just crushed by that yeah
so
here's some what I would call low-level
gaslighting that parents do to their
kids
hey Mom that hurt No it didn't
shut your mouth and sit down
hey Mom I'm really hungry no you're not
shut your mouth and sit down you're just
doing that I gotta go to the bathroom
you're just doing that because you want
you right so that's that's that can be a
little over gaslighting or hey Mom
last night you yelled at me and it
scared me I didn't yell at you you're
just hearing things again you're always
making up stories about me or hey Mom it
was really scary when you I didn't do
that
gaslighting is about power
it's about control and it's using
disorientation or self-doubt or
dishonesty as as your tool some people
gain control by just yelling they're
I've got bigger muscles than you I'm
bigger than you some people gain power
especially in a household and we call it
the one down position
like
okay okay I guess I just won't eat then
if everybody needs three pieces of pizza
I'll just I I'm fine I probably need to
lose five pounds anyway that's that's
like that's a way to gain control
another way to gain control is by
gaslighting making everything excessive
aggressive versus gaslighting that okay
I'm not gonna eat now I can lose well
it's the definition doesn't matter as
much as it's just a way to try to take
back control of a room that you feel
you've lost control of sometimes dads
scream and yell sometimes mom's
screaming you out slam cabinets that is
a body that's disregulated and it just
becomes over emotive I need to regain
power
some get real dads are the worst my wife
calls it Sunday afternoon dad
when I you can feel the atomic energy
pulsing out of me and I'm just sitting
there on the couch
and my kid will say Hey Dad I'll go what
but I don't yell I'm quiet and then the
kids know whoa just don't go around dad
and then they're like man you're hard to
be around on Sundays I'm like I didn't
say anything I just say I'm being
violent with my silence right or moms
like around the Thanksgiving table I
guess
I didn't cook it right so next year I
guess we'll just go out because I'm and
that's the way to go no Mom you did a
great job you're so good right it's a
way to regain control gaslighting is a
way to gain control is
everybody's off kilter
everybody is questioning their own
experience of reality because somebody
who's smarter them or bigger than them
or has more control or autonomy is
telling them that their lived experience
is wrong
and so if your children grew up with two
parents with ADHD
and they were y'all were all over the
place and Scattered by the way my kid is
growing up with a dad with rampant ADHD
it's a context it's not an excuse I
still got to work to be on time I still
get right but my kids growing up with
that and so I've got to be cognizant of
what he's going to experience Downstream
and so
I here's my bigger question
why are you going to why are you
debating your kids on their stories on
their lived experiences why do you feel
the need to say hey you're remembering
this wrong instead of saying I'm so
sorry no I don't I I don't argue
actually with um it's just that term has
come up okay and
um my daughter my youngest one will
um she she is openly admitted that
she'll make up things to try to hurt me
okay
um because of
um the fact that she thought my husband
and I should get divorced and we didn't
we chose to work out a lot of the issues
why do you give your daughter a vote
um probably because she's threatened
suicide in the past that that's even
less that's even less of a reason to
give her a vote my kids do not have a
vote into my emotional regulation
they don't have my permission to hurt my
feelings
now it doesn't always work like that my
body will will react yeah right my my
the last conversation or
um attack that we had I
um
I stayed like the soup Uber calm like I
thought who are you not that I've ever I
don't I'm not the one who loses the cool
and gets super super crazy but I just
was able to step back and just listen to
what she was saying and I was like well
um okay and you know sorry you're
hurting right now and then I just I took
myself and I said I can't talk to you
when you're like this and we agreed that
if we wanted to have conversations about
any of these issues that we do it in
front of a therapist
um but when she doesn't get her way it's
it's like full-blown attack and then I
just have to but you how old is she
um 18. 18. so I would sit down with my
child who's 18 and say I have some
boundaries
and I don't allow people
I don't allow adults
and allow kids
to call me when they're struggling and
use me at to throw grenades at as a
Target so that they make them they can
feel better about themselves
I don't allow that I don't allow my boss
to call and yell at me so he or she
feels better about themselves I don't
allow my friends or family or strangers
to use me as a verbal punching bag so
they feel better about themselves and
most certainly I'm not going to let my
child who has admitted to me whenever I
get down I just lie about you because I
can I can twist a knife in your back or
in your front I don't care I I don't
allow that so from this point forward
when you call and you're in one of those
moods and you're trying to hurt me to
make yourself feel better I'm out of the
conversation I'm just opting out I love
you too much for that and I have too
much dignity and self-respect for that
and yeah they put it just put a period
at the end
right the um and when you said about the
boundary that's actually what the
conversation was about she she wanted to
watch a movie in her room and using my
Amazon account she wanted me to give her
the password no to my Amazon account and
I said yeah and that's not a boundary
I'm comfortable sharing I said I've got
it on I'll I'll put it on your TV
um but she couldn't find the remote she
said and I said and it's on the TV out
here so you could watch out here but she
she lost it and you know my struggle is
I'm trying to get
um make sure she graduates high school
because it didn't happen last year and
because of did what you did did what you
did last year work
well she's a still alive and she
re-enrolled in school so I'm not sure
because things were changed because last
year I was separated from my husband and
we were living in two places seeing each
other
um but that didn't seem to make it
better for her us being separated I
thought maybe she would be able to get
that breath
of not being around the Powder Keg
um but it didn't happen and I was able
to catch my breath and then look back
and help
um you know fix my part of the
relationship or at least make steps
towards fixing it right and is he
becoming a safer place for your daughter
to be around
um did you just refer to it as a powder
keg if I'm a 17 year old girl I'm out I
can't I can't it's too disregulated I
can't be around that it's he
uh he is much better but they
um neither one of the two
um acknowledge any growth and because
they still have a lot of
um trauma from the childhood and it the
problem was um I worked second shift so
they were home
um with him and I wasn't there to
mediate like apparently that's the thing
I do all my life so yeah you got to stop
that if you have an abusive husband
he's got to be away from the kids
or here's what they're gonna do they're
going to turn to adults who never talk
to you all again
and if he's not safe good for them for
getting out because you should have got
him out a long time ago and you know
that
and you're free to work through it great
wonderful it sounds like your daughter
is in a
hyper chaotic environment relationally
physiologically psychologically it feels
chaotic and my guess is they also do
what go ahead there's there's also
there's also the weed factor in there
where they both think that that will
help with their anxiety and depression
and so hold on hold on hold on
whenever a kid who's 18 comes to me and
says I have to do this
my response is not man you got to quit
you gotta quit drinking right help like
you gotta quit smoking weed
my first question is good Lord what has
happened in your home that is so chaotic
that this is the only way you can
navigate through it
and they're probably smoking weed right
now and because it works
it's a terrible long-term strategy but
it's better than the alternative
which is it's sitting inside of a of a
ping ball
like a
sitting inside of a
I don't know uh what do you call it a
bingo ball Turner right that's the world
they live in inside of a blender
all right is that fair
um yeah just some some degree it's
because there has been change with him
they just won't interact with him if he
walks in the room you know my daughter
jumps back like he's on fire
um and they won't
um or they haven't been able to
um he's offered to sit with them in
therapy to go to a counselor he's going
to counseling but
um
I've had her in and out of counseling
but for whatever reason she'll bail on
the people or we've had struggles trying
to connect with providers because of
schedule Insurance all that and I said
I'll pay out of pocket and they go I
can't
um and okay well and we'll schedule you
in six months and she's saying somebody
at school now but it's um
I can't even I don't even know what to
do with all the even the radioactivity
from her
um
outside of him yes it's it's it's a part
of her now
you can't expect there to be a great
summer
after she attempts suicide or suicidal
ideation
a great summer that 18 years of
collective chaos suddenly dissipates
this is Years Years okay so you're gonna
have to be patient with your with your
child and I know they have an adult age
18.
um but there's a little girl in there
that's still protecting herself from her
dad because nobody else would or nobody
else did
and I don't know what Dad did I don't
know if he was yelled and screamed and
scared the little girls or if he was
abusive I don't know
do this and that one but their bodies it
was just
just that tense
to you
soak up and their bodies are telling
them not now and so I would honor that
I would say you have to be respectful
in this house
but you don't have to hug him
if you don't want to sit down and have a
one-on-one conversation you don't have
to do that right now
he's working on it
and he has to be a grown man and know
that he sowed seeds for 18 years and
this is the fruit
and you can't sow seeds of chaos and
rage and anger and screaming at your
little kids
and they get mad when they grow up and
have to have alternative ways to try to
self-regulate because they didn't learn
that at home
and I got no skills
and the two people they were supposed to
be anchored in the most
were I mean we're Jello right there was
nowhere to Anchor into and they felt
like they were untethered like it's just
part of it you got to be respectful and
you can't you can't make up lies about
me you can't throw grenades at me I
won't be here punching back
and
I have to understand the chickens come
home to rest
so they're here
and now we have to ask ourselves what do
we want this to look like in 10 years
let's begin healing that way your kids
can or your husband can talk the talk
and talk the talk and I'm going to
counseling
those girls will
feel safe when their bodies tell them
we're safe
which means he's going to have to act
differently for a long period of time
he's gonna have to act different he's
gonna have to provide a safe environment
he's gonna have to write those girls a
letter and say I'm sorry
I wasn't who I should have been
and I'm trying to be different now
and my hope is over time
you'll come to love the new me because
I'm working really hard at it
but I'm not fighting with my kid over an
Amazon account I'm just gonna tell him
no
I'm not fighting with my kid over the
definitions of gas you're a narcissist
you're a guestler those are the two most
overused internet social media nonsense
descriptors
that are actual Diagnostics right it's
just throwing her I'm not I'm not gonna
do that you can have your story and I
could be sad that you have bad memories
of that I can be heartbroken and
grievable
and then I'm going to be on about being
the adult and about trying to grow
adults I'm going to change my
relationships moving forward because
that's all I can do
your daughters deserve that in you do
too
we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back
as you wrap up today's show
it's one of Kelly's favorite band she
has a tattoo on her neck behind her ear
The Gaslight Anthem
in honor of gaslighters everywhere
song's called boom boxes and
dictionaries and it goes like this I
took a drive today I thought about you I
thought about a friend who passed and
how much we just went through I saw the
Shine off the hood of a Cadillac the
sunshine off the hood of a Cadillac I
thought about some things I said and
some I would take back I thought about
how fortunate I feel to be alive and if
you're scared of the future tonight
we'll just take it each hour one at a
time it's a pretty good night for a
drive so dry up those eyes dry up those
eyes I still love the way you smile I
still love the ocean we should remember
to slow down more often and maybe we
will great wisdom slow down more often
look around find beauty it's there I
promise we'll see you soon